it began peacefully on June the 9th with
a march against a bill for an
extradition deal with China and the
protest movement might well have ended
then if Hong Kong's chief executive
Carrie Lam had heeded their demand to
though absolutely if out a man had
succeeded with the withdrawal of the
bill to safeguard our freedom nothing
would have happened
Benson Howe never saw himself as a
frontline activist but that's what he's
become he's been arrested and forced to
leave home I told my dad we're going out
to fight for the rights we deserve we
had a big fight and after that he said
move out move out if you don't want to
stay at home anymore Benson was also
there when protesters smashed their way
into the heart of Hong Kong's government
the debating chamber of the Legislative
Assembly many wearing the hard hats and
face masks that have become symbols of
this leaderless movement as the long hot
summer rolled on the air became more
toxic
[Music]
it was now a color war men in white
chasing and beating those in black the
color of the protest movement white
terror I said again white terror but
terrorism aided by foreign hands is how
Beijing defined it after its liaison
office in Hong Kong was attacked and
two-faced mainland owned businesses were
also targeted as were transport links
subway stations were vandalized and
forced to shut
Dunham's were closed and thousands of
flights cancelled after protesters
occupied the International Airport
arrivals lounge Chinese leaders have
repeatedly warned they would send in the
People's Liberation Army to restore
order yet that still hasn't happened
they fear that if they would mobilize
the People's Liberation Army you
garrison in Hong Kong then China will
lose face because after 22 years of
Chinese rule they have not one hazard
mines in Hong Kong
police figures reflect a society tearing
itself apart at least two deaths more
than 10,000 tear gas canisters fired and
almost 6,000 arrests more fatality
seemed possible after students turned
their university campus into a fortress
the firey standoff with police becoming
a defining moment of the unrest in spite
of the violence local elections went
ahead with voters sending a clear
message of support to those agitating
for greater democracy a few days later
there was another setback for China's
leaders u.s. president Donald Trump
signed into law a bill aimed at
protecting human rights in Hong Kong and
punishing those deemed responsible for
suppressing them many of the protesters
I've spoken to during the past few
months concede that deep down they know
they're not going to win but they also
stress that their movement represents
the best and perhaps last opportunity to
achieve more democracy Adrian Brown
al-jazeera
Hong Kong